[Musique]
durant des siècles les nôtres sont
restés cachés sur terre
mais elle était ténèbres nous ont
retrouvé
il en va du destin de tous les êtres
vivants
[Musique]
une écrou arrive
pas ah je croyais qu'on était pas
amené un humain ici moi je suis personne
je vois rien j'entends rien je vois même
pas qui me parle là
ce n'est pas notre guerre
Optimus nous devons nous faire confiance
pour protéger ce monde que nous
partageons
il est si grand que ça ce mec il mange
des planètes donc ouais carrément plus
grand qu'une planète
à la fin
tout ce à quoi vous tenez
ce sera englouti
il y a peut-être un autre moyen de
sauver notre monde
vous n'avez jamais rien affronter de ce
genre
[Musique]
qu'il vienne